you've probably seen plants either in
your house or if you go for a walk
you've seen parts of the plants twist
and turn in all sorts of directions and
if you observe closely you'll see that
oftentimes it looks like the plant is
twisting or turning towards the light
and what we're going to do in this video
is study that phenomenon a little bit
more so in general whenever we're
talking about an organism twisting or
turning or changing direction because of
some type of external stimulus we call
that tropism tropism and in the case of
turning or switching directions because
of because the external stimulus is
light we would call that photo tropism
photo tropism and phototropism is the
general term for any type of organism
turning direction or switching direction
or or moving in a certain direction
because of light and it could be moving
towards light or it could be moving away
from the light now most of what we
observe if you were to go see a forest
you'll see that there might be a a patch
in the camera or there might be an
opening in the canopy where the light is
coming and you will often see trees and
plants moving towards that light growing
towards that light so they are turning
towards it this would be called positive
phototropism if for some reason there
was some type of a plant that was moving
away from it that would be negative
phototropism which is a little bit less
or salaat less usual especially for the
stem of a plant but we might talk about
that in future videos but what you
typically see is positive phototropism
like this
and so the question is is how does the
plant do this what what causes it to
turn in the direction of the light in
the case of positive phototropism
well the key actor here is a molecule
called oxen it's oxen and oxen is a
phyto hormone so this is a Fido Fido
hormone and it's a fancy word for this
is just a molecule involve
called in the actual plant growth and so
what happens let me zoom in here on this
plant let me zoom here on this plan and
to be clear we know ox and ax but all of
the mechanisms by which the distribution
of oxen changes or how it gets activated
or deactivated isn't completely
understood and this is still an area of
active research but what we know happens
so let's say the light is coming from
that direction over here is for for
various reasons or for some reasons you
have an increased concentration of
active oxen on the side of the plant
away from the light so you're going to
have more oxen in this case since the
light is coming from the left you're
going to have more oxen on the right
then you're going to have on the left
and what the oxen on the right is
causing to do it causes the cells on the
right side of this stem right here to
elongate so if we were to zoom in so let
me zoom in over here so let me take that
part of the plant and if I were to zoom
in if I were to zoom in and if the cells
I'm just kind of a two-dimensional view
here let's say on this side these are
the cells and on this side these are the
other cells now if we have more oxen
more of this vital hormone on the right
hand side right over here that we have
on the Left what we know happens is it
causes the cell walls where there's more
oxen to break down a little bit more and
so it allows those cells to stretch or
elongate and so what's going to happen
let me see if I can draw this is the
cells on the right hand side are going
to stretch are going to stretch or
elongate because of the auxin because
they have more oxen in them than the
cells on the left-hand side and since
these have a higher concentration of
actor active oxen they stretch and if
the right-hand side gets longer than the
left-hand side what's going to happen
well the plant is going to bend to
to the left so the plant is going to
bend like that because now the
right-hand side is longer than the
left-hand side so this is what we know
about oxen it's a Fido hormone that
whatever it is in higher concentrations
and it's active the cells there are
going to elongate which will cause this
bending now the things that are still
being studied is well what caused there
to be a higher oxygen concentration on
the right hand side and all of the exact
mechanisms by which the oxen is actually
acting we know things like it creates a
more acidic environment which helps
break down the cell walls but how does
that you how do you have a higher
concentration here on the right well in
many plants studied it's actually the
blue light that causes the sensitivity
so I drew this as yellow but really I
should draw this as blue light that
causes the sensitivity although it's not
always blue line it could be red light
it could be other frequencies of light
and the various theories and it might be
some combination of it is when you have
the light on one side of the plant that
it causes one possibility is maybe it
causes the aux-in to migrate from the
side with the light to the side that has
less light another possibility is if the
auxin is migrating down from the top of
the stem that it might cause more to
migrate where there is less light then
when there is more light there's other
possibilities that somehow the light
deactivates the aux-in on the left or
maybe allows less oxen to be produced
then what would happen on the right so
these are all possibilities and this is
what's interesting about science is that
there's always more for us to understand
but what we do know is that this type of
positive phototropism which you will
often see in the forest or you leave
you'll even see on a house plant if you
put it next to a window it'll Bend
towards the window it will often bend
towards the window it's caused though
the key actor here is oxen and the
distribution of oxen changing in
response to the light and then the oxen
and that the oxen distribution increases
on the side away from the light when you
have positive phototropism
now this picture here it looks like this
might be phototropism but this is
actually a mutant plant that actually is
lacking oxytocin so it's growing in all
sorts of random directions but it's just
interesting to look at